people who fail they will give up their
dream before they do what they hate when
you put your convenience ahead of your
goals you're saying I don't want to go
do the work to do that thing I'm gonna
wait till it's easy and it never will be
like everybody thinks I'm so lucky and
I'm like you're lucky you went to high
school parties
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message be prepared
to make sacrifices over to you Marissa
Pierre so the first thing that people
who are incredibly successful do is they
do what they hate they are fully
prepared to do what they hate to get to
where they want to be and and people who
fail they will give up their dream
before they do what they hate to do
people who are very successful they
never ever ever wait for motivation they
do it because when you do it you become
motivated a great writer working well I
just wait and I really motivated to
start writing this book know they get up
at 4:00 in the morning they don't want
to and they start to write and then of
course they become motivated so you wake
up in the morning and you go you're not
gonna go yeah it's 5:00 a.m. I'm putting
on my running shoes and going for a walk
up Laurel Canyon of course you're not
gonna do that you're gonna wake up go
god I really hate working out but
Marissa said successful people do what
they hate to get to where they want to
be of course the wonderful thing is that
when you do what you hate first enough
times it starts to become natural like
I've got to do my taxes I'll do that
first thing I've got to confront someone
I'll do it first and so I still to this
day wake up and think oh I don't really
want to do that
so I'm going to do it first because what
I do want is to belong to that group of
very very sick
well people so I know what the
membership is and every time I don't to
do something I think I don't want to do
it but what I do want is to belong to
that group so I'm doing it first and
it's it's a great way of thinking
because it starts to move you around
wanting to do it for all the right
reasons many many years ago and I met
someone who wanted to be a rock star
that was his ambition actually
particularly wanted to be a drummer and
he was a very young married man with two
children to support and he was going for
a lot of auditions and of course all the
additions take place during the day and
every time he had a job they wouldn't
let him take time off so he decided he
would have to work nights in order to
audition during the day and the only job
he could get was a job he hated he was a
taxi driver and he hated it but he did
it but he just wasn't making enough
money Caesar okay I have to work in
McDonald's I get more money I can work
nights I'm free to audition and about a
month before he'd applied to work in
McDonald's he'd been for an audition to
be a drama in a band he didn't you know
who the band was and the day he was you
to start working McDonald's which he
absolutely hated even the thought of he
got a call to go you know that band you
audition for it's actually Simple Minds
and now you're the drummer and Simple
Minds that he never worked in McDonald's
or drove a cab again for the rest of his
life but when he told people that story
they'd all go oh I would never work in
McDonald's oh my god I'd never degrade
myself by driving a cab around London
and I'm like don't you think you're
missing the point his ability to do what
he hated is what made him a rockstar
because he had to have his days free to
rehearse and audition but if he had your
mind sir I'd never do that he would
never be a multi-millionaire rock star
it was because he was fully prepared to
do what he hated to swallow his pride to
keep his vision in mind I want to be a
rock star I must be free for auditions
how can I do that well I have to work as
a cab driver and in a fast-food
restaurant which I hate but I'm gonna do
it because it's gonna take me to my goal
and it did but the people who laughed
him and said I
wouldn't do that none of them a rockstar
you need to put your goals ahead of your
convenience
most people have big goals but they
never realize them because they want it
to be convenient for them you want it to
come to you you're waiting for that
event to come to your city you're
waiting for that mentor to come find you
you're waiting for the perfect time to
get started
stop it achieving your goals won't be
convenient it is not going to come to
you if you wait if you put it off you
will be in the same spot one year from
now as you are right now today you need
to put your goals ahead of your
convenience so I look at my tour as an
example I'm about to hit the road do 90
days 23 cities and I'm getting a lot of
people messaging me and DM and me saying
hey Evan man it it looks so great I
really wish I could come but you're not
coming to my city and listen maybe
coming to see me isn't at the top of
your list and that's totally cool but if
it is you need to put your goals ahead
of your convenience like I may not come
to your city your favorite mentor or
speaker or the person who can make that
connection for you may never come to
your city and so you need to go off and
do the work I have an IG morning show
where people come usually local
entrepreneurs in Toronto on my Instagram
when we do a morning show together and
somebody messaged me from New York and
he said hey I'd love to come on your
morning show but I have to take a bus
from New York
can I pick a day so I'm know I'm gonna
be there I said yeah you're gonna come
from New York we'll make it happen so
this guy takes a 13 hour bus ride across
the border from New York it gets in at 6
a.m.
gets up to my studio for 9 a.m. to be on
the show with me we chat a little bit
and then he goes home and spends another
13 hours on the bus to get back that's a
guy who is eventually gonna win that's a
guy who puts his goals ahead of his
convenience and you need to do the same
thing whatever the thing is in your life
that you want to accomplish there will
be people who can help you there will be
moments in time that will allow you to
make a massive leap forward and default
nature is gonna be uh well it's not here
you know it's not happening in my city
so whatever I'll wait
and you cannot take that approach to
your goals if you want to come to my
tour then pick a city I'm actually
rewarding the people who come furthest
away one of the bonus prizes is I'm
doing a coffee shop meet up two days
after the event in the city for two
hours where it's gonna be me and three
people and one is gonna be random draw
from people who show up and the other
two guest spots are gonna be from
whoever came furthest I'm gonna reward
whoever comes the furthest away to have
the coffee shop one on three with me for
two hours but even if you don't get that
reward if chasing your goals is no extra
bonus just the self-respect like just
the momentum you build in yourself to
say here's an obstacle I'm not gonna
succumb to it when you put your
convenience ahead of your goals you're
saying I don't want to go do the work to
do that thing I'm gonna wait till it's
easy and it never will be but when you
flip it and say this is my goal I know
it's not gonna be convenient that thing
that's in front of me that's difficult
I'm gonna go destroy that thing so I can
get to where my goal is when you start
taking that kind of action that kind of
momentum it just changes who you are it
just changes the trajectory of your life
and so you need to put your goals ahead
of your convenience I'm gonna give you a
three-step process to do it it's gonna
be scary but you're ready for it
step number one write down your next big
goal what is the big goal that you have
like what is missing in your life in
your business what do you want to
accomplish you have goals you know what
you want to go off and do write down the
next big thing that you want to
accomplish it if you did that thing you
would feel amazing about yourself and
the impact that you are having what is
that thing write it down step number two
write down three things that you need to
accomplish it to accomplish that goal
what are three paths what are three
things that you need to do three things
you need to learn through people you
need to meet what are three things that
have to happen so that you can go off
and actually accomplish that goal so
it's not just some hope but some dream
like I wish that thing can happen one
day when it's convenient for me now
we're gonna make it happen
and what are the three things that you
need to do to actually go and make that
thing happen write them down and then
step number three is pick the most
inconvenient thing on that list out of
the three and do it today
you mean our people to finish it today
but you can start you can make momentum
you can buy ticket to the tour you could
schedule a meeting with a friend you
could send an email out to somebody
that's scary
you could start working on proposal for
that client that you want to pitch like
whatever is the most inconvenient thing
the thing that you've been putting off
the thing that for the past three six
nine months have just been sitting there
because you're too afraid because you're
worried you're gonna fail because
there's no momentum in your business yet
that thing today I want you to start
building momentum right now commit to
somebody else make a decision go off and
start making some immediate progress and
momentum on the thing that is the most
inconvenient for you and if you have the
courage to do that if you have the
courage to follow those three steps if
you have the courage to say this is my
big goal if you have the courage to say
here are the three things I need to go
off and do it and if you have the
courage to say today I'm picking the
most inconvenient thing and I'm gonna
start making progress on it even though
it scares me this is the start of an
incredible life an incredible business
for you and I'm pumped
now I've got a really special bonus tip
for you I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is one big thing that you
have been putting off that has been
inconvenient for you and now you're
ready to take action on let me know put
it in the comments below
everybody thinks I'm so lucky and I'm
like you're lucky you went to high
school parties I can work I went home
75% of my weekends during my college
career taking Amtrak not even Axela no
first-class Amtrak hitting a bull
sandwich which I kind of loved and I
missed that sandwich get get into New
York not New York
not even New York which would be fun
Woodbridge New Jersey train station at
like 8 o'clock my dad would pick me up
we drive home and then I would wake up
at 6:30 in the morning and work in the
liquor store on Saturday and then leave
back to Boston on Sunday and now I'm
lucky it's hard to it's hard to think
you're lucky when you nobody else and if
you want more marisapeter check out the
top ten rules video I made on her the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there belief without talent
will take you far further than talent
without belief you're just not good at
that I want you to change that voice to
a cheerleader